Good morning, everyone. This is AACR NCI
Session 7, lucky number seven, and I want to tell you why
you're lucky to be here.
You're lucky to be here because this is a focus on
obesity-related cancer,
and it's growing,
literally as well as figuratively, in its importance.
This session's going to be an hour long or less.
We'll see.
But not more than an hour. We're going to stick to our time.
I'm going to briefly tell you about NCI active funding
opportunities, and then you're going to hear from our
metabolic dysregulation and cancer risk colleagues
about
what the NCI funding is doing to move obesity-related
cancer research forward.
Then we're going to quiz our panel with some
interesting questions about the future of obesity-related cancer
research, and then it's time for your questions.
So we're going to ask you to save your questions
to the end.
I think
we hit advance.
Okay.
Oh, no, I'm sorry.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, it's just showing.
All right. So,
when you work for the government, you definitely shouldn't have any financial
relationships. That's for certain, okay?
So
this is the topics we're going to talk about.
First of all,
why we think that MEDOC may be a springboard to other obesity-related
cancer studies that I hope that you guys will apply for,
and specifically, the currently active notices of
funding opportunities, the parent grants, of course, which you can always apply
to, planning grants if you're not quite ready yet, but
you have a great idea, and finally, weight loss and weight
loss independent mechanisms. And I want to focus especially on those
weight loss independent mechanisms, because if it's just weight
loss, that's not good enough. We want to know what
else is happening once you've had the weight maintenance.
After all, you can't keep losing weight forever. You turn into a skeleton, right?
We don't want that to happen to you.
So I'm not going to read all of this stuff.
Suffice it to say that there's a lot of speculation as to the
mechanisms that might impact obesity-related cancer
risk.
And you're familiar with a lot of them, the microbiome, aromatase
levels, adipocytes, inflammation,
gluconeogenesis, so on and so forth.
And
we have our panelists here.
Ed is representing the first Brigham and Women's
grant. Deirdre couldn't make it. Mary's here from the University
of Utah.
The South Carolina folks, unfortunately, were not able to make it.
Lee Bing is here. Bing Lee is here. Bing, he's going to shoot me.
Bing Lee.
Sorry, Bing. Bing and I go way back. I should not have done that.
And then Eliza's here from UT. That's the
better UT. Oh.
There you go. All right. I hope I'm not retracting.
Then Ella-
Yeah.
... who's-
It's okay
... very local to Washington, DC.
She's also here.
All right. First of all, the parent grants.
Of course, there's the parent R01, which hopefully you guys are familiar
with, and if not, it's PA25301. Any
idea pretty much
that you have, you can submit
to the parent R01. The challenge there is what your study
section's going to be. You may not get into a study
section of a bunch of basic scientists, and myself, as a physician scientist, would
go, "I'm going to die because my gene,
it doesn't necessarily impact the kind of
clinical-related research I want to do." So ideally, you'd find
something a little more specific to your idea, but if not, you can submit it to the
parent R01.
There's also these
exploratory grants, which are the ones with more
preliminary evidence, either if you have a clinical
trial, that would be the 306, or if you don't,
304.
And then there is the planning grants, okay?
The U34s.
By the way, ours is pretty much more independent where the
U grants, like this MEDOC consortium,
NCI is more involved. Sometimes our
scientists like that, and sometimes maybe they don't.
But U grants,
the government folks like myself are a little more
involved in the implementation of these projects.
So for the planning grants, it's not for the collection of preliminary effect
data.
You can collect feasibility data,
and an additional effect data, and it's meant really is to fill a gap in cancer
prevention and control trials.
And by the way, in my division, we have ULOCHNET, CP-NET,
CP-CTNET, and NCOR. I'm in the division of cancer
prevention,
and my two colleagues are in other divisions at NCI.
They'll briefly tell you about that when they come up.
So there's
alsoTwo
grants really, PAR-043 for R01s
and 044 for R21s. Preliminary
grant, the R21, and the more advanced, fleshed-out
project for the 043 grant.
And this thing was initiated a bit earlier than the ones
I'll talk to you about in a second, and essentially it's how bariatric
surgery
might decrease cancer. The data's really strong that bariatric
surgery does decrease the risk of obesity-related
cancer. We've got hundreds of thousands of individuals that
have been analyzed in multiple studies suggesting
that it does decrease risk, and it's not only because of the weight loss,
although certainly that's a part of it.
But really the more interesting question, as I brought up a minute ago,
was what are the weight loss independent effects, and actually does it
decrease the risk of all obesity-related cancers?
Because some of the data says maybe not.
It might increase the risk of colorectal
cancer, at least with the Roux-en-Y gastric bypass, because of increase in
bile acids in the lower GI tract. Anyway,
so relevant topics to study. Look up this funding
opportunity. It'll go into the kind of questions, and then the
bullet three is the one I was mentioning about colorectal cancer.
But we want to know about the mechanisms of action, and again, especially the
weight loss independent effects.
We know that weight loss or obesity is a driver of many
cancers. It took us a while to figure out, and still
we're debating on whether or not weight loss
in an obese individual, does that decrease risk?
But the data suggests, especially if it's substantial, usually
10% total body weight loss or greater,
that you do have a cancer risk reduction.
And speaking of that,
GLP-1s du jour. Today we have
another approved drug, and tomorrow maybe two.
We now do have two oral approved agents,
semaglutide and orforglipron,
and it's once a day pill, not bad. Otherwise, you can get
your weekly shot.
We have two FDA... We actually have many.
Well, we have three agents approved for obesity in the
absence of diabetes, liraglutide, semaglutide, and
tirzepatide,
but I'm sure more to come. Retatrutide, who knows? Probably soon.
Anyway, again, we're looking not only at the effect of
weight loss, because at some point you're going to have weight maintenance, and
what happens with weight maintenance?
Is there a benefit to taking these agents
long-term for life, whatever? The answer is
we don't know for sure. I'm talking about in the absence of diabetes, of
course. But maybe,
and there's strong evidence that they do have weight loss independent effects, such
as insulin sensitivity improvement,
anti-inflammation activities, and so forth.
So thank you.
Now we'll move on to our next session.
Okay, great.
Thank you for the invitation from the NCI to share our
work about the MEDOC Consortium, the Metabolic
Dysregulation and Cancer Risk Program.
I'm Liza Makowski from the University of Tennessee, Health
Sciences in Memphis.
And on behalf of our consortium, who you will meet over the next 20
minutes, I'm happy to discuss how MEDOC is bridging the gap
in a transdisciplinary approach to obesity and cancer risk
with the MEDOC Consortium.
And
we have no disclosures.
this is our outline. So today, we will highlight what MEDOC has built over the
past three years. It's a unique and innovative and
powerful resource. We have shared infrastructure,
harmonized cohorts, and cross-species mechanistic
platforms. We'll share how the MEDOC is poised to
deliver impact
in obesity-related cancer prevention.
So first, we'll talk about the obesity cancer gap, which you heard a little bit
from
Ed.
So we're in the middle of an obesity epidemic.
We know that overweight and obesity affect more than 70% of
American adults, and obesity is on a trajectory to
surpass tobacco as the leading preventable cause of cancer.
We heard yesterday from Dr. Litae how important tobacco and obesity are
as preventable risk factors.
At least 13 different cancer types you can see are causally
linked to obesity and overweight, with emerging evidence of
earlier onset of some cancers in younger populations, which is concerning.
As the NCI and the NIH reaffirm their commitment to
nutrition-related chronic diseases, the obesity cancer link
is both an urgent public health problem and a
defining scientific opportunity.
So despite decades of epidemiological evidence
supporting the obesity cancer links,
the mechanisms remain undefined.So in 2020,
a trans-NCI working group, which you just heard a little bit about,
identified three gaps. First, there's an absence of
large, well-annotated human studies paired
with mechanistic preclinical models reinforcing
causation. Second, there's limited data on whether
mechanisms hold across populations with different whole person
health profiles. And third, there are no validated molecular
risk tools for obesity-associated cancer risk
stratification.
So the NCI concluded that addressing these gaps
required a new and innovative infrastructure.
And as a result, you heard a little bit, is that they launched in
2021, two companion funding opportunity announcements
through this trans consortium across
multiple divisions,
called the MEDOC. And Dr. Tram Lamb, who's not here today,
wrote this manuscript that you can read a little bit about for their thinking to
develop this MEDOC consortium. They describe this
solution. Our teams were honored to be selected, and here we
show our NCI collaborators and partners in the
MEDOC through our trans-NCI
collaborations.
The MEDOC solution is this transdisciplinary consortium.
We started in 2022. So this is a translational
and transdisciplinary group. In our investigation
span within and across multiple sites,
we use team science to study the complex relationship between obesity,
metabolism, and cancer risk.
Our overarching mission, you can see here, is to reduce cancer burden in
populations
affected by obesity and metabolic dysfunction by turning those
mechanistic discoveries into prevention for all Americans.
And our core values listed here support our mission and for
continued growth of our consortium.
And last, our esteemed external advisory board have
been with us since the inception of our consortium.
They have helped review our projects, our progress,
our proposed manuscripts, and they've also attended
in-person and virtual meetings. So it's been a true honor to work with these
esteemed colleagues.
Next.
Here we go. Thank you.
Hi, everyone. My name's Mary Playdon, and I'm an associate professor at the
University of Utah and the Huntsman Cancer Institute.
The MEDOC uses a shared definition of metabolic dysregulation that
considers a number of mechanisms that you can see depicted here.
We're interested in the metabolic interactions that drive the hallmarks of
cancer. Our approach is to treat metabolic dysregulation
as a networked process that can be quantified and then
compared across populations, across cancer types, and across animal
model systems, and then linked to clinical and cancer endpoints.
As you know, obesity is typically measured as a ratio of weight to height squared
or body mass index, BMI, and this has been a really
powerful tool for public health. But what we're realizing now is
that two people can have the same BMI, but have vastly
different obesity-related cancer risk profiles based on their metabolic
health. And so there's more to the story here.
And this has motivated our metabolism-centric view of
obesity-related cancer prevention.
But to target this metabolic state, we need interventions that
normalize the environment beyond just the number on the
scale.
A core strength of the MEDOC consortium is triangulation of
the obesity cancer research questions across preclinical,
population, and clinical
studies. So each site in MEDOC is investigating
why obesity drives cancer risk using both
preclinical and human studies, and it's supported by our
multidisciplinary and translational teams.
The base of the triangle here is a bidirectional loop between
preclinical research and population science.
What we're seeing, the signals coming from the preclinical studies
can inform what we measure in our population studies.
And likewise, the associations that we observe in our population studies,
which include causal models to
develop causal evidence in using population data,
can then be tested mechanistically.
And this is how we establish causality beyond
just correlation, and it's helping us to promote rigor and reproducibility.
Everything feeds into the apex here, clinical trials, because we
want to build foundational data to develop molecular informed
obesity-related cancer prevention interventions. That's the ultimate goal.
And triangulating across these three domains is helping to give us confidence
in our findings. It's helping us to establish generalizability.
It's helping us to understand whether what we're observing is relevant
across different cancer types. And it's also helping us to design
smarter interventions, lifestyle, surgical,
medical, obesity interventions.
But these are grounded in specific metabolic signatures.
All of our complementary research teams, they span different
mechanistic targets and different cancers, but now we're also
collaborating across our sites to integrate.
CERMET at the University of Utah, that includes myself, as well as Dr.
Cornelia Ulrich and Dr. Scott Summers as multiple PIs, are
investigating ceramides as causal drivers of metabolic dysregulation and
colorectal cancer risk. So we're doing this using three parallel lines of
evidence. First, in prospective cohorts, we're developing and
validating a ceramide-based colorectal cancer risk score.
We're testing the effect of different modalities of weight loss, including
bariatric surgery and incretin mimetic weight loss therapy
for the effects on this risk score.In large-scale genomic data
sets, we're examining how ceramide-related
genes are linked to colorectal cancer risk.
And in parallel, in DES1 knockout and obesity mouse models,
we're mechanistically confirming the ceramide colorectal cancer
relationship, and we're testing a
first-in-class DES1 inhibitor that lowers ceramide production, as well as different
dietary interventions.
Hi, everyone. My name is Bing Li, and I'm a professor at the University of
Iowa. My co-investigator, Dr. Sonia Sarph, is a breast cancer
surgeon in the university hospitals.
As part of this consortium, we're working on a protein called
AFABP.
AFABP is short for adipose fatty acid binding protein.
As we know, fatty acid binding protein and its family members play important
roles for fatty acid transport,
energy production, and cell signaling.
So in this project, we try to understand how different high-fat diet
induce lipid dysregulation through AFABP, and also
we're investigating or evaluating AFABP as a circulating
biomarker and potential target for immunotherapy.
In doing so, we're collecting patient samples from University of
Iowa Cancer Center, including patients from women with
high-risk breast cancer. In parallel, we're also conducting
animal studies, including conditional knockout mice and
patient-derived xenograft models.
So far, we have developed multiple anti-AFABP antibody for
immunotherapy and have confirmed the therapeutic efficacy in
multiple mouse models.
So if you have any questions regarding to our project on
AFABP, please feel free to contact me. Thank you.
Hi. Good morning, everyone. My name is Ed
Giovannucci. I'm a professor at the Harvard School of Public
Health. My co-multiple
PIs are DeeDee Tobias, also at Harvard, and
Dr. Xuehong Zhang, he was at Harvard, but now
he's at Yale
University. So our project is focusing
on
visceral fat-induced inflammation as
a potential
indicator of cancer risk and mediator of cancer risk.
So the basic premise of our
project is that we have two sets of cohorts.
In one set of cohorts, we have information on
direct measures of visceral adiposity through DEXA scan
and also have
inflammatory markers, a 384 inflammatory
proteins
panel, plus glycemic markers such as insulin
resistance and glycemic
glucose. And so our first goal is to come up
with an inflammatype, which is essentially a molecular signature
of proteins
related to visceral fat-induced inflammation.
And then once we have that, then you just essentially need a blood
sample. And the first thing that we're going to do is look at
GI cancers, particularly colorectal and liver
cancer, as low-hanging fruit that we
hope are related to visceral fat
and induced inflammation.
That's the beginning, and then obviously we can look at other cancers.
So we're very happy to share our inflammatype when it's
ready. Thank you.
Hello, I'm back again.
I'm Liza Makowski. I'm PI of the WELCOME study, which is
Weight Loss And Cancer Outcomes in the Mid-South.
And my co-PI is Joe Pierre, who was at University of Tennessee and
now is at University of Wisconsin-Madison.
And so our team is examining how obesity-driven gut
microbes and microbial dysfunction, including microbial-derived
metabolites, impair immune
surveillance and how that affects obesity-induced breast cancer
risk.
We're integrating across multiple human subjects,
patients undergoing bariatric surgery, and
GLP-1 receptor agonists for looking at both
obesity and weight loss over time.
And then we're also using translational models to
use multiple complementary preclinical models using mixed
genetic backgrounds. We use carcinogen models with Catherine Cook
in the audience here, and models of
interception to look at both how we can affect
obesity and weight loss, looking at impacts of
microbial dysfunction, microbial-derived metabolites on
immune surveillance, and cancer
risk, as you can see in our little cartoon.
And then next,
so I'm representing REMEDY as well, because none of them could be here
today. REMEDY is Reducing Metabolic Dysregulation in
Obese Parent and Child Dyads. And we could see there are three
MPIs, Dr. Hebert, Hofseth, and
Murphy.
And so REMEDY is
conducting the
only randomized clinical trial in our MEDOC consortium
by implementing an anti-inflammatory diet based on the dietary
inflammatory index, the DII.
And they're testing whether reversing metabolic dysfunction and
associated inflammation can reduce markers of
colorectal cancer risk. So REMEDY, like
most of our teams, is conducting parallel preclinical model studies,
looking at mirroring models of colorectal cancer and
also obtaining patient-derived adipose secretomes,
testing those on human cells and organoids,
providing mechanistic validation across their studies.
And thank you.
Good morning. I'm Ella Temprosa from George Washington
University. With my partner, Loretta DiPietro,
we lead the Coordinating Center for MEDOC, and we provide
scientific leadership
and administrative leadership for the consortium.
And in the next few minutes, I will give you a very whirlwind tour of the
infrastructure that supports MEDOC.
This infrastructure, the connective tissue that allows everyone to speak
the same language for collaborative synergies.
This unifies the five
U01 projects and the coordinating center.
This is the MEDOC mosaic. We've moved beyond single-site
limits by combining prospective cohorts, new
clinical cohorts, along with leveraging
well-established prospective cohorts and trials.
With hundreds of thousands of participants and decades of follow-up,
the triangular approach that we are using is unique and
unmatched. Our collective research footprint truly
covers the map, reflecting populations all across
America.
Now, looking at our membership of 89 consortium
members, of the best mind to solve this obesity cancer
puzzle, nearly half of them, and some of them are here in the
audience, are early career investigators and trainees.
And that's very intentional from our point of view.
We're building a durable framework that will outlast any single
study. We're also an open consortium through our
affiliate members, which we have now seven.
We welcome outside investigators to join this mission, and it's a very
simple process
to make our science inclusive and synergistic across and beyond all
nine institutions.
So the collaborative projects is how we
come together. It is an integrated effort funded by restricted
funds. We now have 23 from three cycles, and
these are not silos, leveraging our shared protocols to drive
the mission.
Our bench to cohort pipeline is in full swing.
Here is an example of how collaborative projects come together to
evaluate GLP-1s and weight loss on cancer risk.
In our MetUpGuard collaborative project, we've exceeded recruitment
goals with 70 participants, and in addition, testing the
same
interventions in mice and other human studies.
As the lead of the coordinating center, we developed our shared infrastructure
with four pillars that transform
individual research projects into a unified platform.
The harmonization, the thing that we worked on the very beginning, we
moved beyond simple BMI
to in-depth obesity phenotyping.
Our common measures are very important to us to make sure that we are really,
truly comparing apples to apples, both in
mice and human studies. Second, our approach to data
generation and sharing is very important, using the same
platforms for
pilot studies. And the analytics backbone is the one that
helps pull all the
data together to integrate with standard model-based
systems biology to move toward predictive modeling
to forecast cancer risk. Finally, we have our
resources already in place, our workforce development, which
is key to our sustainability. This
is the MEDOC biorep that shows you the
repository of samples available throughout MEDOC.
The MEDOC Knowledgebase, which is a repository of all
prior and future studies for MEDOC that will
relate hallmarks of metabolic dysregulation with cancer
risk. And underlying this is this complicated,
but we figured it out, a knowledge base based on graph
databases with more than 190,000 relationships so
far and growing.
Most importantly, we are investing in the next generation of
transdisciplinary researchers.
Here, some of them, Sarah is in the audience,
and we're really proud of them and help support
them go to the next level.
So in the next few seconds, I want you to think about how to
engage with MEDOC.
With MEDOC, we've built this infrastructure
that we are open to share with everyone and
happy to engage with through our affiliate
membership.
So why study obesity-related cancer risk?
Obesity isn't just a population statistic.
For cancer precision prevention,
we have to identify which biological drivers lead to
carcinogenesis, in whom and when, and when to
intervene.
Prevention is the long game. Because the signals are subtle, the
mosaic of a consortium is non-negotiable.
On a personal note, I lead the coordinating center not just as a
biostatistician, but as a daughter.
My mother is currently in the thick of her battle with cholangiocarcinoma,
and seeing her fight reminds me every day that data points are
people, and biomarkers are windows of
opportunity. We do this so that the next generation
not only have better treatments, but have prevention
strategies. If our infrastructure shortens that path for
even one family, then it's worth it.
So MEDOC is open for business. When you need
data, specimens, or a partner to test a new intervention,
examine new mechanisms, come find us.
Let's change together the map of cancer prevention.
Thank you.
Well, so
I'm a surgical oncologist, and the only reason I bring that up is because
I dealt with cholangiocarcinoma.
It is,
wow, a tough one
because there's the intra and extrapatic bile ducts.
You can't get them all out. You can't get all the tumor out, and
I hope your mom
hangs in there. We have another colleague, I won't mention who,
apparently their relative died of cholangiocarcinoma, so it's a
tough disease. Anyway, so we're moving on to
some questions here, and I'm going to quiz the panel. What do you think?
I used to teach school, so I'm going to continue in that vein,
see if we can stump the experts. So,
the first question, and Wan Ping, my colleague at
NCI, and Anil, my other colleague, will have other questions for them, but
I'm going to shoot the first one.
So to the panel, in your view, what are the top three gaps in
our understanding of how
obesity-related metabolic
dysregulation increases cancer risk?
Who wants to take that?
Okay. Thanks, Ed.
This is a very challenging question.
When we talk about obesity and the cancer risk,
the first thing stands out to me is that when two people
with similar level of obesity
could have very different outcomes.
So that suggests there must be something very important missing.
So to me,
the top three gaps I can see include,
the first, we need better biomarkers.
When we try to use the currently used to
measure obesity, like BMI or even DEXA, it's not
just enough.
Those
measurements
don't capture the underlying dysregulate
metabolism that can really drives cancer risk.
We need a better biomarker that's measurable and it can provide more
information for clinician.
And the second, I think we still don't know, fully understand the
biology.
So for example, when we're talking about factors like
adipokines or lipid
species or metabolize that drive cancer, we don't know the
mechanisms, and we also don't know how those factors
affect cancer cells as well as the tumor microenvironment.
I think the third gap will be
for translation. So far, we haven't taken
the
biomarkers identified in the lab to the clinic and used
them to identify patients, which patients are truly at
risk, and intervene in a precise
way. So that's why I think
this MEDOC consortium come in. So we are working
together. We're trying to evaluate,
from a perspective on multiple factors like
circulating factors, ceramides, diets,
metabolites from microbiota, and we also try to
validating those biomarkers using large cohorts of
human
populations. So at the end of the day, I think we should move
beyond
measuring body size
and starting measure biology. So in that way, we can really
know who is truly at risk and stop
cancer before it starts. I'll stop here. Thank you.
Anyone else?
Sure. Yeah, I think Ping gave a great answer.
Hope we pass, but
Not annoyed. B minus
I may make it worse. Yeah. No, the only thing I want to add
is from an epidemiologic perspective,
we have studied obesity-related
biomarkers
and cancer. One of the great advantages of MEDOC
is that we can integrate many markers.
So like, our group is focused on inflammation,
but that's just one potential pathway, and these
pathways, inflammation,
immunology,
sex hormones, they're all interrelated.
So I think
we can find correlations in one study looking at one marker, but
ultimately we have to put them all together in some kind of network,
systems biology. And I think we can only do that if we have all the data
in one place. And I think with all the groups with different types of
expertise,
I think that this is a great mechanism to be able to start
to entangle some of these issues.
Thank you.
So we're going to, just to get all four-- We have four questions by
the way, and we have 20 minutes, and so we're going to move on to question two.
All right.
So I have a couple of questions. So the first one is
that for those of you that
conduct animal-related research, are you
considering using other
preclinical investigations to replace
animal research given the new
NIH focus in this area?
Sure. I could help answer that question.
Yeah, so we understand that there is a new focus to kind of
diversify instead of using just animal models,
and our teams are already doing some of this workWe're
using mixed genetic backgrounds, we're
doing organoid models. We're isolating
adipose tissue samples from humans, and then we can
culture or co-culture secretomes on
either human cells or organoids.
But one thing we really have to recognize is that obesity is a
chronic disease and it involves multi factors.
So not just one tissue or another tissue,
but also the microbiome. It's a systemic
issue. So we have to be very cognizant of what we're using.
For example, PDX models, where we might study a human
explant of a tumor, but it would be best to use a humanized
immune system because we need to understand the interaction across
the risk of cancer or responses.
So in general, we are
doing our best to model systems in our
labs and then correlating that with what we're seeing in our human
subjects. And one great advantage of studying metabolism
is that it's kind of species agnostic.
And so if we have certain metabolites we can use, like the ceramide risk
scores
derived
from our Utah collaborators, and then look at our mouse model ceramide
profiles related to both obesity, weight loss, and
cancer onset in models that are either genetically driven,
carcinogen driven, or
models of early cancer intervention or interception.
Any other?
Yeah, I would like to share a story actually.
Five years ago, when this MEDOC consortium RFA was out,
as a
lab focusing on animal studies, I'm interested in this
MEDOC
proposal, but I don't know if my work fits their requirement.
So I send a letter to Tram and
Dr. Sauter asking, as an
animal-focused lab, can I write this grant?
And they tell me very clearly human components is a
must.
But when I look back five years later, when NCI focused on human
studies, I feel I'm so lucky to be in such a
visionary team because we already implant this
procedure five years ago.
All right.
My second question is that in your opinion,
how the NIH MEDOC consortium
impacted what we know about
how obesity impact cancer risk?
So for the past three years,
we've been building this amazing group of
collaborators, infrastructure
that allows us to really target this
cancer obesity nexus. And
so I think that putting this together, as Bing said,
visionary,
a unique resource,
an important and
I think very important resource to really answer the
question because not one group can answer it, right?
And we all have to work together to answer this question because
it's a complex multisystem question,
and there's many things going on in our bodies that we're trying to
uncover. And so,
there's the metabolic health,
and we hope that you guys will join us.
I'll just add, what's been interesting is the rapidly changing
obesity treatment landscape. And we had to pivot halfway through
to--
Liza and I started recruiting bariatric surgery patients
undergoing treatment for weight loss.
And with the advent of incretin mimetic weight loss therapy, we've
had to pivot to recruiting those patients in addition, which
has led to rich opportunities in terms of data
collection and samples to address these emerging questions.
And so I think by building out these clinical cohorts,
so our cohort is embedded in clinical workflow, and Liza's
is more community driven recruitment,
but we're establishing the resources to kind of address these
questions in real time.
Wonderful.
So my name is Anil Boal. I'm the program director at the
NCI Center to Reduce Cancer Health Disparities.
I'm co-moderating this session with my NCI
colleagues, as well as this distinguished panel of speakers here.
So,
the last question
we are asking them as to what would be the next step since you
guys have galvanized up to three years conducting team
size. So where do you see yourself moving
forward down the pike in terms of addressing
obesity-related cancers?
Yeah, I'll start to take this on.
So ultimately, kind of our vision, and what we're
working towards is
AI-powered single site and pan-cancer
multi-omicBiomarker precision, obesity-related cancer
prevention, risk stratification.
But we need to take that to clinical validation, and we need to take that to
trials
to validate these profiles. And at the same
time, we're kind of working towards molecular
informed precision obesity-related cancer prevention interventions.
I'm a nutrition epidemiologist, so I'll just speak to some of the work we're doing,
developing precision dietary patterns that are targeting these pathways.
But then we need to take those forward into diet intervention
trials.
So that's one example, is really moving this to
trials and then moving biomarker work into clinical validation.
So anyone else? I want all of you to chime in-
Yeah
... on this question.
So I guess from a biostatistics point of view, I'm a
biostatistician, it really is
having the evidence available to move anything that we've
found to clinic, right? That's our ultimate goal.
But there's also this time and place.
You have a dynamic system that
we're trying to understand. There's a long latency to cancer
risk development. And when along that
dynamic, things happening in your body, things
happening outside in the environment, how are all these things coming
together? And that's the evidence we need to really say, okay,
we have the answer. We have the tools available,
and really, how are we going to translate this for
access to all, right? Not just the people in our local
communities, but in outside, like
somewhere in West Virginia, as Ed had told us- ...
where people have to wait so long to see their PCP.
So something that is accessible is really something
that we really want to strive towards.
Excellent. Fabulous. So at this point, we have still seven to 10
minutes left, and we are opening up the floor for
Q&A session. So please feel free to ask questions,
because this is the best opportunity, and beyond this, you guys
can interact with all these distinguished panel of speakers.
I was told by our technicians here to please come up
to the mic.
Yes.
Gunnar Boyden, University for Medical Science in Little Rock, Arkansas.
And I should be part of you guys. You're doing a great job.
And I have the mechanism
on hand you're going to look for. My question is, when we talk about
obesity, there was a mention that we should go past BMI, right?
And you collect all these biospecimens.
Well,
I'm not a clinician. I don't see patients, but most times these specimens are
taken in the morning after overnight fasting.
While you guys think that that is the right sample you want, because in my
little mind of obese people that eat all the time, they're
probably not fasted.
So do you think you might have to get a sub-study where you see
what time of the day or after eating you want to take your
samples? Because when the human you study is already
repairing everything and is doing good, looking like a lean person
metabolically, you're not going to find your
obesity-related markers.
I think it might depend on the biomarker that we're targeting.
So,
my fellow, Sarah, in the audience did a methodological study to test that
question in terms of our ceramide panel. Does fasting status matter?
Does tube type matter that you're collecting your sample
into? And it will be
sent for publication very soon, but it turns out fasting status,
it did not affect some ceramide base risk scores that we
calculated in terms of how people were stratified into risk
categories. There may be some individual molecules that are
affected, but I think it's going to depend on the biomarker
panel.
Can I take that one for a second?
Sure.
Oh.
I'm sorry, Ella.
Go ahead.
So,
speaking from a clinician point of view, fasting is
important. Fasting is important primarily for consistency,
because you want to evaluate trends over time.
If you don't know
the variability of when the person ate, what they
ate,
and all the rest,
you really can't
look at trends. So certainly in the clinic, we want
fasting
collected samples.
So
the beauty and the curse, I guess, of a
large mosaic of cohorts, that you're able to
understand how fasting affects different mechanisms,
right? And so that's the beauty. So we have
pragmatic cohorts, but we also have
clinical trials where they're very, very
methodical, and they really stick to...
I've worked on diabetes prevention trial for a very long time, and we're
very, very... You take that fasting sample eight to 12
hours, not outside of it, to make sure that you're getting what you need.
But the beauty of a consortium is that you can see if those
variability, heterogeneity in the way you collect things really
affect that relationship that you're trying to understand.
Mm-hmm. And I could speak to, we're doing
prospective collections, and we're collecting fecal
samples, and I thought, "Oh, this might be hard for people
to come in and carry these things." But they're really
excited to participate. So if we ask them to be fasted, they show
up fasted, and they bring in their samples, and they come, and they get their blood
drawn. They jump on the DEXA. So people really want to help
understand cancer risk
Because everybody knows somebody who has cancer.
And so I think I agree with Ed that at least if they're fasted,
the noise is kind of gone. But then using the vast
database, we can then look further into extended fasting.
Yeah.
You have another question. Yeah. Please go ahead.
Hi, my name is Kasra Rezvani from University of South Dakota.
I saw some panelists particularly working on colorectal
cancer. And my question is that in the last two
decades, early onset colorectal cancer basically become a major health
issue. Is there any differences in term of
biomarkers and obesity
between early onset and late onset?
Because still when I look at the literature review, I
cannot find a very direct relation between the
obesity and early onset.
Maybe I can start.
Yeah, early onset colorectal cancer is very important.
At least in our study with the inflammatypes, we will have a
relatively small sample, but we will be able to look at some of the early
onset cancers. There are some data that
suggest that obesity is a risk factor.
Having said that,
anecdotally or just
there are a lot of people get early onset cancer that actually seem very healthy
and lean, athletic. So it's obviously
complex, but
obesity has been established as one of the risk factors.
I'm not sure it's the driver of early onset obesity,
but obviously the rates of obesity have been going up,
particularly in the
younger population. And I believe
six or eight of the obesity-related cancers have gone
up in early onset. So I think obesity is definitely
an important part of the, not just colorectal, but other like
pancreatic cancer. So yeah, that's definitely something
that makes this consortium particularly relevant in today's
environment. Thank you.
Thank you.
And I may add onto that, it's becoming a NCI priority
area as well. So we have NCI as whole is looking into early
onset malignancies, so it's one of the priority areas.
And the etiopathology is different between the late
and early onset diseases.
Yeah, please go ahead.
Yes. Yeah. This is Banyan Styles. I'm from University of Southern
California, and I work on liver cancer, which is heavily
related to steatosis and obesity, and include
cholangiocarcinoma. I'm very sorry for your mom.
So,
my question here, I'm very thankful that NIH
and Ed initiate this and the panelists for coming here.
I'm wondering if you guys can elaborate a little bit what
is available data-wise, tissue-wise,
sample-wise to the community for us who are
doing the work, we can acquire and either
validate or
do whatever we need to do in our labs.
So
I'm not a mouse person, full disclosure, but I was
thinking about this because I was talking to Cindy
about her liver cancer. I don't know if you've seen her poster, maybe online you
could see it, but it's really fascinating how there's different mechanisms
that when you transition from normal to
steatosis, to liver. But I was telling her, "Cindy,
we need to find out if these mechanisms are real," and the only way to do that,
thank goodness we have MEDOC, is that the mouse
models have been run. A lot of those
experiments have been run, but they have also, in
addition to doing their own breast cancer or
other cancer, colorectal cancer, they've also harvested those
samples are available in freezers.
Angela always tells me it's in the freezers.
Yeah.
And you can go and
access those to see if those mechanisms ring
true.
So could I address follow up? So
I've been one of the folks designated as the obesity and cancer person,
at least in our division. So I'm reviewing a project
specifically related to MASLD,
and HCC.
Suffice it to say that the data,
literally phase three data
for
semaglutide and phase two data for tirzepatide,
the GLP-1 agonists, shows a dramatic
reduction in MASLD
NASH, which is a more severe form, and indeed some evidence of
fibrosis
reduction. So I would say studying these
medications would be a good start.
All right. Thank you. So we have a lot of samples from-
So before the session is closed,
what about a big round of applause for the distinguished
panel? And we will extend this Q&A session.
You guys can interact with each and every one of them to establish a
collaboration. So please feel free.
Big round of applause for the panel.
We can hang around in the back.
Oh, we have-
I think five minutes.
We have till 11:15.
We have seven minutes.
Yeah.
Yeah. I think we have till 11:15.
No, we're done with our talks
Yeah, we have more time.
Yeah, go ahead. Go ahead, Pam, questions.
Yeah.
I can ask here or there. Yeah.
Go ahead.
I think we have till 11:15.
I just have one question, actually.
Oh.
I
work on an obesity-related gene called FTO,
and
it causes changes in lung cancer. So it causes obesity, but
at the same time, it also causes lung cancer.
Would that be something of interest to the NIH?
We're not NIH.
You need to talk to them.
You have to talk to those guys. But
lung cancer has not been associated with
obesity, not yet. So
one future direction that we're thinking about is that
to really understand, is it just the 13 that we're talking about, or is it
more than the 13? And that's something that we're really interested in.
Okay.
This is something new. So actually, I was just saying,
so that's what we found.
We'll invite you. We'll invite you to talk to us. Ed's standing right next to you.
Yeah, I could talk to him. But I just thought maybe if you guys have some ideas
about it, right?
Okay, well-
But you haven't heard about this, apparently.
So I'm going to give the mic to somebody else who wants to ask a question.
Yes. One thing, it's really interesting to say,
because metabolic dysregulation could affect the whole body, but why is it only
increasing or associated with increased risk of certain cancers?
So those are things that we're interested in.
Yeah, actually this gene affects the metabolism,
and it's-
Yeah
... a mutation in this gene makes people obese.
Yeah.
But at the same time,
this gene is changed in,
I know in lung cancer it's changed because I studied it, but it's
also-
Okay
...
changed in some other cancers. So it has a role in promoting cancer,
but at the same time, it also promotes obesity.
Yeah.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay.
Just make a very quick comment. It's interesting that
Mendelian randomization studies of obesity-related
genes are related to lung cancer.
So it suggests at least some of the metabolic effects of obesity are related to
lung cancer. Now, BMI is not related to lung cancer.
It's even-
No, it's not.
It's not, but-
Not yet
... because smoking is a big
risk factor for lung cancer. Smoking reduces subcutaneous
fat, it reduces lean mass, but actually
increases visceral fat.
Right.
So BMI may be a
useless marker for lung cancer, but
related metabolic abnormalities-
Yes, that is right
... can be related.
It causes metabolic changes.
Yeah.
And those metabolic changes actually could cause cancer.
Right.
And it also changes some of the target genes-
Yeah
... which then promote cancer. So that's just something new I started studying.
All right. Sure.
So I was just wondering if this would be of interest to the consortium.
Yeah, thank you. That's very interesting. Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Sure. We have two people waiting in the back patiently.
Go ahead.
Hi, I'm Brittany Ivory. I'm actually a pediatric oncologist at Children's Hospital
Los Angeles,
and I do work on physical activity and cancer during therapy.
I was curious, you guys mentioned the data on increasing childhood
obesity.
We don't have- Oh, is it still there? Yeah.
Yes.
We don't have the same data on obesity and increased risk of cancer, but
we have increasing data on worse outcomes
patients, particularly leukemia,
and obviously a lot of our survivors are obese and at risk of secondary
cancers. And I'm curious if you guys have started any work in
pediatric cancer or are interested in doing more work in that area.
Well, we're interested. At the time, we're just
focusing what our expertise is on.
I know St. Jude has a cohort, adult
cancer survivors, and
I know that they've been really interested in growing their
investigations into obesity and those subjects.
But right now, I don't think any of us are studying pediatric cancers.
No, not pediatric cancers, but we are thinking about
the future, so we're open to discuss-
Yeah
... future directions with you.
The one thing is that NIDDK is very interested in
pediatric obesity, as you know,
and there is huge studies right now that are
collecting data and information and maybe something that you'd
be interested in to go for an ancillary study, like the
Discovery study that's sponsored.
They're collecting many samples,
and maybe cancer can be one of those outcomes of it.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi, my name is Charlie Rusco. I'm an environmental epidemiologist
at OHSU.
I really liked this comment about moving away from site specific
to biology specific, because when you're doing GIS and
geospatial things-
Yeah
... people are always like, "What's your site?" And I'm like, "That's a really
strange question for me, because I'm thinking about the environment, which
obviously affects multiple sites." So anyway.
Yeah, and anyway, I loved that comment.
And this is separate. So since
I was previously on the East Coast, and this wasn't on my radar at all, and
since I've joined OHSU-PSU School of Public Health,
there's a group there
formed of different epidemiologists, some of them are nutritionists,
but the kind of movement in
other fields towards weight inclusivity
and
like I have written things on obesity-related cancers, and then
I've talked to these people, and I'm just saying this as a kind of canary
in the coal mine maybe, but maybe you're really up to date on this literature, but
I'm not seeing it at this conference at all, that obesity as a
proxy for health is incredibly problematic,
has a lot of racism in the history of that.
I don't know. I just wanted to-Like hear your thoughts on that because I'm
not hearing that at this conference whatsoever.
It's kind of like obesity risk factor cancer, and it's not
really... Yeah. Anyway, it was new to me two years
ago. I kind of have looked at some of my publications and been like, "Oh, that
is maybe problematic how I'm using BMI." I'm just wondering if you
guys have any thoughts on that.
Yes. I agree. I've had a lot of interactions with patients and
patient advocates about their views on
the words that we use and how we're describing
obesity and cancer risk. And,
on the flip side,
patients or participants are very motivated
when you have a metabolism-centric view of health, so
focusing on metabolism is a real motivation, and so we're
kind of
harnessing that
in our recruitments. Mm-hmm.
Yeah, likewise, when I speak to the public,
they
think cancer is caused by this chemical plant down the road, and
it's hard for them to understand that it may be
their own body. But then we also know that obesity is not
because necessarily what they're eating, but it's access
to care, it's access to primary care physicians, it's food
deserts, it's
increasing cost of living. And so we're actually
collecting social determinants of health in many of our studies,
so we can look at those things. And I actually just got a collaborative
project funded to do geospatial, which I don't do, but I'm
bringing in an affiliate who is looking at access to care.
And in Tennessee, there's people that can wait two years to see a primary care
doctor. And they
can't get their diabetes treated, or they may not get access to GLP
drugs.
Mm-hmm.
And so we're looking at who has access to that type of care
and then associating with cancer risk or cancer death in
certain counties with Tennessee and South Carolina.
But yeah, your question is very encompassing because we know obesity,
for so long it was blame the person-
Mm-hmm
... but we see that it's actually environmental, the built environment, all these
things. And,
I agree, it could be focused on more.
Yeah. Thank you.
Sure.
I think it'll be really interesting with the new drugs.
But-
Yeah
... yeah, I definitely have that
kind of thinking that we don't want to do the carbon footprint by BP,
blame the individual for the really big systemic issues.
Yeah.
So we want to make sure we intervene at the right place.
Mm-hmm.
I'm still very new to the fat justice work that's going on in my school.
But if you are interested, Hannah Corey
came over from the-- worked in the Nurses' Health Studies, did a lot of nutrition,
and is over there working on that now. But it's kind of-- Yeah.
I'm learning a lot from being there, so just wanted to share.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you so much.
My name is Yuening, I'm from Hawaii. Oh, oops.
It's working now. Hello.
Like driving.
Okay.
Of course. So I'm from University of Hawaii, so I'm working on
the Hawaii population colon cancer, especially the
onset of colon cancer in native Hawaii.
So I'm working with our medical center surgery, for connecting the
cohort, and I'm a bioinformatics data scientist working on
their whole genome, microbiome, metabolomics, and-
Mm
... even using the digital pathology.
So we do find the obesity-related microbiome and then
metabolomics relate to the Hawaii, especially
native Hawaii,
early onset colon cancer.
Mm.
So I wonder, how can we join this kind of program,
so contribute, or collaborate our work together?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Yeah. This is of
incredible interest in Utah. We have a very large
population of Native Hawaiian and Pacific Islanders, and it's a population we're
targeting as well, so we should talk.
Oh, University of Utah. Wonderful.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
Yeah.
And also, it's a very special population, right?
We know that Asians, they develop
diabetes at lower BMI, so it's not the BMI
that really should be a target. It's something else, like the
metabolic health. So, we would love to hear more
about your cohort.
Thank you.